we can start
then first of all good morning
what we can say is that the
situation in Italy is quite critical
and more days pass and more the situation
worsens and if other taxes increase
also the work of the boys because i
boys then we parents must
live therefore here is however
change things because it's impossible
that he lived that must go
continue with or with a pension or
without salary because one is unemployed
I don't have much to say, I love you
go on so bye
the south is forgotten and we are
forced to leave here
this is the problem because we are
studying we graduate there is no work
many many minds many in intellectuals
in short, graduates all run away
away everyone goes away and moves
abroad
the beautiful from home you see if you do or there
you say but work where when in one
cage a lion and without eating than not
can eat because fasting attacks
the trainer
and so we are here we are without resources
economic
first the work and after the reforms thanks
you understand career in the pool one that is
beaten we will not be able to sell and in atari
and aspires to kiss touch 50 euros
and who is at the head of mine but bindi euro and 15
free franc I understand Francoist Mary
lampa I would like you to eat rods
vicaretti renzi not made to divide you are
doing a good job both in Europe and
in italy you are good at the end of the world
dear renzino you are all cheaters e
thieves cheaters and talkers
talkers talkers and do not conclude
nothing sicily is dying italy is
died to us including my dogs
politics we do not give a damn and dear
matteo I love you so much I know them
I have known you for a long time
Florence
you did well I respect you owe yourself
fight with these Italians we are
completely devoid of civilization
start with the people of Catania and the shops
Chinese whatever and come and not
only we are giving ourselves the place of
work is throwing us out to us
above all it is the boat of all
these people had nothing to do with it
so all these bad people
must return as before must return
sicily sicily
milano undermines everything as before
situation is bad bye